the religious aspects of Christmas
celebrations appear to be on the decline
a 2017 study from the Pew Research
Center shows that 46% of Americans
celebrate Christmas primarily as a
religious holiday that's down from 51
percent back in 2013 the most Reverend
Michael Curry do you remember him is a
Presiding Bishop of the Episcopal Church
he first made headlines in May when he
delivered a rousing sermon at Prince
Harry and Megan Markos Royal Wedding he
joins us today with the true meaning of
Christmas here in the studio
Bishop Perry we welcome you thank you
you believe that the message of
Christmas is really all about love you
really did that hard these days when
we're living in a nation that's so
patriot that's so vitriolic and so mean
and so hateful
you still say hold on to love hold on
yeah hold on to it because it's all we
got now the truth is if love is just a
sentiment then then it doesn't matter
but love is a commitment and one of the
passages that speaks about Christmas is
John 3:16 it speaks about the
crucifixion of Jesus but it also speaks
about Christmas God so loved the world
that He gave His only Son it is love
which is tied to giving not taking
giving we give gifts as a symbolic way
of reminding us that God showed us the
way of love which is to give and not to
count the cost because that's all we got
it's always great on that if you'd asked
me years ago what's the opposite of love
I probably would have said immediately
hate yeah and to be sure that's that's
part of it but the real opposite of love
is selfishness love is the opposite of
self-centeredness and self-centeredness
is the most destructive force in human
relationships and political ones but
love is the antidote love is the cure
love is the way well I think the cure
and the antidote is what many people
need but how do we do that when we are
so polarized
in the nation today I think that's where
we have to make a decision and a
commitment that's why I say loving magic
and we're mad - yeah but make a
commitment I'm gonna live in the most
loving way possible today if I'm a
member of Commerce
Congress I'm gonna live in the most
loving way possible and I'm gonna look
for legislation that is about loving the
neighbor that is not about my
self-interest but about the common good
that's what love looks like in political
relationships in economic arrangements
in business and commerce and in daily
life and that kind of unselfish
sacrificial love is a game changer in
all sorts of life it has been quite a
year for you we saw you at Meghan and
Harry's wedding then I saw you at the
funeral President George HW Bush what
stands out for you you know in all
honesty on both occasions at the funeral
President Bush the word love recurred
over again and at that wedding I mean
the truth is it was wonderful the truth
is we kind of all showed up two billion
of us showed up to watch two people tell
the rest of us that they love each other
that was a standout line for me and I'm
very curious about you because you have
had quite a year but I was reading and
you had two very big major many people
didn't know you before that day that you
actually still get nervous you're an
eloquent speaker you know what you're
going to talk about what are you nervous
about nervous I get nervous before but
once I'm in the moment then then I'm
focused then you get into zone and you
just kind of keep going but I get
nervous because you don't want to mess
up no I mean there I was at the wedding
two billion people I didn't want to
scratch my nose 2019
other than love what do you want us to
remember what I really want us to
remember is that there's one God who
created all of us and if all of us have
the same parent that means we are
brothers and sisters siblings of each
other then we need to treat each other
and treat this creation like we are
brothers and sisters we need to remind
it of that you can't get that messaging
up so nice to meet you it's good very
much for coming today god bless you god
bless you too Bishop curry